今天想聊一個很有意思的案例，來自德國柏林的 Nanolope 這家新創公司。他們拿到了一筆 80 萬歐元的種子前融資。
80 萬歐元，這數字在 DeepTech 領域不算特別高吧？他們到底做什麼，會讓我想花時間聽？
他們做的是，把建築物的表面，像是牆壁、天花板，變成熱能儲存系統。聽起來是不是有點出乎意料？一般大家想到節能，都只會去換冷氣、換窗戶。
等等，把牆壁變成熱能儲存系統？這怎麼做到的？難道要在牆裡面塞電池嗎？成本會不會很高？
他們用的是一種高密度熱能儲存材料，把這些材料做成面板，然後可以安裝在牆壁、天花板和地板上。這家公司 Nanolope 是在 2025 年由 Dr. Felix Marske、Eric Matthes 和 Dominik L. Schreiber 共同創立的。
喔，所以不是什麼黑科技，只是把材料應用在建築上。但這真的有用嗎？能存多少熱能？效果撐得久嗎？
Dr. Felix Marske 說過一句話，他覺得永續供暖的關鍵在於現有建築。很多舊房子需要快速且經濟的改造方案，不能有大工程。他們開發的熱儲存面板，就是為了這個目的。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，建築業是歐洲最大的能源消耗者之一。舊建築的暖氣系統和隔熱差是個大問題。
對，而且他們強調的是「被動式」的冷熱儲存系統。不是主動去耗能，而是讓建築物本身就能調節室內溫度。
嗯，所以就是靠材料本身的特性來維持溫度，減少冷暖氣的使用需求。這聽起來比較像隔熱材的升級版，但又比隔熱材多了「儲存」的概念。
沒錯。他們的解決方案主要是針對公寓大樓、商業大樓，像旅館、辦公室、咖啡廳這些。Nanolope 說，他們的面板可以讓室內溫度更穩定，減少二氧化碳排放，也降低能源峰值負載。
所以意思就是，夏天比較不容易過熱，冬天比較不容易過冷。這樣可以省下不少電費。但這種改造會不會很麻煩？
Nanolope 強調，他們的面板可以在不進行大範圍翻修的情況下進行改造。這對很多房東來說很重要，大翻修通常耗時又花錢。
這一點其實不容易做到。如果我是個小店老闆，我要考量停業時間、裝修成本。如果他們的方案能快速、低成本，那確實有吸引力。
而且他們發展材料時，是按照「綠色化學」原則。面板是用歐盟當地生產的植物性可再生原料製作，不含稀土，生命週期結束後還可以回收。
這不錯，符合現在的環保趨勢。那如果從創業者的角度來看，我們可以學到什麼？
我覺得是「二次利用」的精神。他們把原本被動的建築表面，透過技術變成主動的能源管理系統。就像我們小店，可能有些閒置的空間或資源，有沒有可能透過新技術賦予新價值？
確實，很多時候我們只想到開發新東西，卻沒想過把現有的東西升級。這讓我想，是不是我的供應鏈或庫存，也可以用不同的方式去「儲存」價值？
或者說，作為一個上班族，是不是也可以把這個概念帶入工作？比如，我們每天處理的數據，除了報表呈現，有沒有可能讓它變成一個可以自動調節、提供洞察的「儲存系統」？
你的意思是，把一些例行性工作或資訊，用一種「被動」的方式去管理，讓它能更有效率地回饋給我們？
對，不只是單純的歸檔，而是讓資訊本身就能發揮更多作用。 Sabine Wolff，IBB Ventures 的主管，就說 Nanolope 的團隊用專業知識、經驗和雄心說服了他們。
所以關鍵還是在於把技術用在對的地方，解決了產業的痛點。他們也用這筆資金來擴大生產、執行初步的試點計畫，還有擴大團隊。
嗯，這確實是一個蠻好的方向。把日常可見的事物，賦予一個你可能沒想到過的新功能。